best python libraries for machine
learning there's a bunch but these are
personally some of my favorites
particularly if you're just getting
started first and foremost pandas this
is great for working with tabular data
then numpy this is brilliant for working
with large and complex arrays but you
can't forget scikit-learn this includes
some of the most important machine
learning algorithms that you're likely
to encounter throughout your data
science career if you're interested in
deep learning then I highly recommend
you also take a look at tensorflow or
pytorch but if you're interested in
getting into something a little deeper
then I highly recommend you also check
out optuner this is an optimization
framework that allows you to eke out the
very best out of your machine learning
algorithms and that's why I think these
are some of the